okay so i guess it definitively
is sylvie at least that's her name now
it could be so the
lofty daughter that's entirely possible
or sylvie odin daughter but
i'm inclined to believe that it really
is sylvie lushton and that's kind of
cool okay so
i have an idea here that i want to
experiment on you guys with
on comics explained we make these 20
minute long videos where i promise you
you'll walk away as a comic book expert
on
whatever character or team that we're
talking about and while i love doing
that i also recognize on here
a lot of you guys like the more
condensed version and then you can go
check out those great big huge versions
when you have the time to do so so i
want to kind of do a condensed version
on sylvia lushton and then talk about
the show and some of the stuff that
really lends credence to the fact that
it really
is sylvie lushton so sylvie lustin was a
character who was basically created by
loki and this comes out of a handful of
different stories right it comes out of
avengers academy it comes out of young
avengers really dark rain young avengers
and then it comes out of thor ragnarok
or thor disassembled so the whole idea
behind this with thor ragnarok thor
disassembled whatever you want to call
it is it the long and short is thor
basically had to destroy all the
asgardians the bigger story they're
focused on something called the ragnarok
cycle which is actually destined to
happen over and over and over again
because they're kind of these enigmatic
beings called the ones who sit above in
shadow that feed on the energy the
asgardians give off whenever they die
and so because they need that sustenance
the asgardians are eternally locked in
this loop where they basically
experience ragnarok
till pretty much the end of all time and
then ultimately the universe is reborn
and the cycle will begin over again and
so in order to end that cycle of
ragnarok thor destroyed idrisil which
wiped out what remained of the
asgardians which included loki
eventually thor returned and then he
rebuilt asgard and brockton oklahoma and
this basically led to him running around
trying to find all the different
asgardians whose spirits had been born
in mortal bodies
and loki took the body that was meant
for sif that's how you end up getting
lady loki during that time
loki and the rest of the asgardians
lived in brockton oklahoma
and loki came across a girl and loki
thought it would be interesting to give
this girl just
insane levels of magical power
brainwasher trick her into thinking she
was actually an ass guardian who had
basically been banished from asgard and
then send her out into the world
just to see what would happen and that's
exactly what did happen that he gave her
these
magical abilities and then sent her into
the world as a banished asgardian she
ended up in new york after that she
started operating under the name of
enchantress kind of fashioning herself
after the character amora the
enchantress eventually she came across
the young avengers this was basically a
bunch of teenagers who operated as
avengers after the original avengers
team was disassembled because tony stark
couldn't afford to bankroll them anymore
eventually they were sanctioned by the
actual avengers team
and then became an official young
avengers team but during that time
period they came across sylvie lushton
and then a handful of other characters
named like coat of arms and the melter
who were kind of operating as an
unofficial version
of the unofficial young avengers team
which was really kind of weird
they ended up fighting each other for a
little while and then they became
friends some of the members were
selected to become part of the young
avengers themselves which i believe
included sylvie lushton and then a
handful of things happened after that
she ended up becoming part of a team
called avengers academy which was
basically an academy where the avengers
trained kids who would go on to become
avengers themselves the whole just
behind that though the secret thing
behind it and the avengers never told
anybody this is the kids who were in
avengers academy
were actually most likely to become
villains and so it was really just one
giant ruse by the avengers to keep an
eye on them to make sure they didn't
actually become villains in the first
place
eventually sylvie left and she got
involved with a handful of other
characters so like caroline lafaye
basically the daughter of dr doom from
the past who was teleported to the
future she got involved with a guy named
parker robbins who was
kind of a weird villain had the infinity
gauntlet at one point in time and he
formed a group called the illuminati not
the
old school illuminati the more modern
illuminati and the whole point behind
that was to kind of operate behind the
scenes and try to conquer the world and
then eventually sylvie met the actual
amor the enchantress who was pissed
because she was using enchantress's name
and so she said okay fine
this is what you want to do then she
whisked her off to some like demonic
version of the 10 realms and said if you
can survive
life in those realms then when you come
back you can use my name and we haven't
seen or heard from sylvie since so
presumably she's dead i have no real
idea but when you look at the tv show
that origin makes a lot of sense right
it works really well
not the young avengers and avengers
academy and all that unnecessary fluff
but how it was that she was created
whenever loki refers to her as
loki she hates that name she doesn't
like being called
loki and so you could literally look at
this story as is playing out in loki and
say okay
so this girl sylvie is from an alternate
reality
what's to say that she was truly created
by an alternate reality version of loki
but she was not supposed to exist
it's one of the things that she says in
the show the tva has been hunting her
her entire life so what if we play this
out right what if we throw out
the craziest theory we can come across
right one crazy theory that i just want
to throw out here
is this theory that like owen wilson and
the judge are actually the timekeepers
or at least two of the time
keepers the third one who knows what
happened there but like i'm gonna throw
that insane theory out there i have
no evidence whatsoever to back that up
i just think it would be cool if it was
true
[Laughter]
i just think it would be awesome if it
was true but looking at this character
of sylvie
let's say that loki in an alternate
reality was not the villain that we know
right he was a cool guy because
that's one of the things to keep in mind
when it comes to alternate reality
depictions of characters especially in
marvel comics just because they're a
villain in the main marvel universe does
not mean they're a villain in
every single universe sometimes they're
heroes in other universes
other times they're villains and other
universes it just kind of depends on
what story we're talking about
but let's say that this version of loki
in this alternate reality
was a good guy he was a hero and let's
say that this girl sylvie was
some young person who was caught in the
crossfire of some conflict or
say that maybe that version of loki was
a bad guy this girl silvie died
loki changed his ways and said i've
gotta fix this girl being killed right
in the same way that iron man would have
done
anything to keep peter parker from dying
during the events of infinity war and
let's say that version of loki
went back in time and basically saved
sylvie or maybe he created silly
whatever the case happens to be
loki himself was involved in the life of
sylvie so much so
that she became the person that she is
maybe she was just a regular person
who basically was saved by loki but
because of the fact that she was
supposed to die
according to the time stream the tva
showed up and said nope she's got to die
we've gotta reset charge this girl she's
gonna be disintegrated from existence
and that's gonna be the end of that and
loki said no that's not gonna happen and
basically sent her out right just
teleported her away and said save
yourself
in the same way that you see loki
teleport that little time device right
it just
disappears reappears what he does with
his daggers different things like that
he did the same thing with her just sent
her away and the tva couldn't find her
right and so they end up just either
getting rid of that version of loki or
resetting that timeline or whatever it
is but that version of loki
ends up dying what it comes down to now
is motivation that's her motivation
right there right it would explain
why she kind of operates with the look
of loki but doesn't like being referred
to as
loki because while she was saved by him
she is her own character it would also
explain
why the tva has been hunting her her
entire life because she's not supposed
to exist
she's supposed to be dead this also
explains why it is that she's running
around and trying to destroy the tva
because
at the end of the day they destroyed her
mentor father figure the person she
cared about whatever the case happens to
be
and so the result of this is she wants
to bring the tva down it's a pretty
loose and flimsy theory i will admit
there's not a whole lot going on there
but it seems pretty basic and pretty
simple and the mcu is nothing
if not that i would like to believe
there's more to her character than just
a petty revenge story
that there's something much bigger going
on that has to do with the tva
basically deceiving everybody
specifically the timekeepers deceiving
everyone but we also got some really
really cool tidbits out of this right
one of the things that we learned that
was solidified again it wasn't my theory
was a theory that you guys came up with
or one that i read but it was basically
the idea that the tva the time variance
authority
all the people who work for them are
basically humans they're variants from
alternate realities now it again
begs the question how are they able to
pull that off right
and one of the theories you guys came up
with is the mind stone we know the
infinity stones do not work in the
offices of the time variance authority
we know that the
the members of the tva have been
brainwashed to basically work for the
tva so what's to say that along the way
they're told that these artifacts things
that could be used to potentially topple
the time keepers
don't work right those are those are
infinity stones they don't work here
right
and that's why people use them as
paperweights because they don't actually
know what they're capable of
because they don't know that they can
use them the biggest issue i can think
of though when it comes to the mind
stone theory is
we know the infinity stones don't work
in the tva for a couple of different
reasons the first reason is because
loki was told they don't work and then
loki tried to use them
and found out they don't work so it's
not like the assistant guy was lying but
this does raise a really interesting
possibility if you look at marvel comics
for a second there is a story in
jonathan hickman's fantastic four or
point in that story when you learn that
what the council of reeds is doing
basically this big coming together of
all these alternate reality reed
richards is there's actually
whole universes that they have that
they've effectively turned into food
storage warehouses
that like there's whole worlds where
they grow crops foods resources
different things like that
and then take those things to other
universes and then drop them off
it's only one step away from considering
the possibility that the timekeepers
do exist assuming they're not owen
wilson or the judge or whoever they do
exist and they don't
live with the tva they exist in like
their own dimension or their own reality
and they oversee or at least partially
oversee the creation of these members of
the time variance authority that
whenever a variant
is captured and brought in that variant
is taken to
whatever that dimension happens to be
and the infinity stone is used there
because when it comes to the stones we
know they don't work in the tva but we
know that every single universe for the
most part not everyone but most
universes
have their own versions of the infinity
stones and if you possess the infinity
stones in that universe who's gonna stop
you so what stops them from grabbing
variants taking them
over to that dimension or that universe
where the time keepers reside
where they oversee this kind of
transition process and then those people
have their minds wiped using the mind
stone and then in turn
are brought to work into the tva it
seems a lot to throw into the loki tv
show especially to cover in a single
episode
that seems pretty in-depth and a lot of
what we've seen has been pretty
simple and straightforward stuff so i
doubt that's actually the case
i love the mind stone theory but i don't
necessarily believe
that's what's going on it's possible
it's entirely possible it's happening
it just it seems a little far-fetched
even when you look at what's going on
with the nature of loki and the mcu
and the the kind of stuff they're
covering adding that in seems to make
things a little more complicated
anyway this episode was filled with some
pretty cool stuff but much like we saw
with one division when we got to about
the middle of the season it's filler
right this is just kind of
informational stuff it's the empire
strikes back equivalent of loki right
the tva strikes back
[Laughter]
one of the things that i really really
loved about this is we got to see so
much personality from sylvie right like
she's not just like this cold-blooded
really crappy person who just
kills arbitrarily honestly i did kind of
like the mysterious version where it's
like man like this chick is wildly
capable
once you actually know who it is and you
see her she becomes a lot more tangible
and then at that point it almost seems
to kind of take away from the mystery
the intrigue and almost the capabilities
of her character but regardless it was
cool to see that whole thing like the
conversation she had with loki
and like them talking about each other's
past or what little we got about her
past all that kind of stuff
it was cool it was interesting right i
dug it right i had a good time watching
it so let me know what you guys think
down in the comment section thank you
guys for watching
and i will catch you all later peace